in this lesson we're going to talk about
exponential functions so this is an
important concept to understand for the
s80 so let's get right into it so the
first thing is you know what is an
exponential function well basically it's
a function with a variable you know is
in that exponent position right so a
general way of writing an exponential
function is y equals a times B to the X
the B is the base and a is the
coefficient is what stretches the graph
or compressive the graph but the B is
like what you're multiplying each time
to get to the next term so if the base
is greater than one then what happens is
it's going to be an exponential growth
function it's going to row to the right
but if that base is in between 0 and 1
it's going to be an exponential decay
it's going to be decreasing as x
increases okay so it's a decaying now
another formula that you want to
familiarize yourself with is this
formula here y equals a times 1 plus R
to the T or y equals a times 1 minus R
to the T this is if something is growing
by a certain rate per year this is what
you want to use if it's decreasing or
you know going down by a certain
percentage each year it's going to be 1
minus R to the T E is what you start
with one represents like a hundred
percent like your original amount and if
it's going up you're going to be adding
that percentage but you want to convert
the percent to a decimal so that's ten
percent point 10 right it's going down 1
minus point 10 if it's going down by ten
percent and then t is the number of
years so that's these are a couple form
is you want to memorize yourself you
want to memorize for yourself and then
also this half-life formula so the
half-life you start with this amount
here that's the original amount or the
amount at time zero the base is a half
because it keeps you know cutting in
half cutting in half and then the
exponent is the time and then the
denominator here is the half-life like
how long it takes for it to break down
to half so we're going to go through
some examples go ahead and pause the
video like normal and go ahead and so
you can do these on your horny will go
from together so the first example it
says a classic car purchase for thirty
thousand dollars appreciates at the rate
of twelve percent per year which of the
following functions models the value of
the car after two years right so go
ahead and pause the video which one you
think it is
hear ye well if we're using these
equations over here okay you're starting
off at 30,000 that's the initial price
of the car it's going up by twelve
percent per year okay appreciating these
is going up it might be a classic car
right yep classic car and then it looks
like we want to find out what the value
would be in two years so if we combine
these together we're going to get 1.12
we have our starting amount 30,000 and
then t is the number of years so it
looks like the best dancer here is going
to be ladders see okay now example
number two it says a radioactive
substance has a half-life of 10 days
okay so after 10 days is going to be
half as much right another 10 days and a
half as much as that you'll amount right
and it's originally there were a hundred
grams how much will remain after 40 days
so go ahead and pause the video see if
you can do this one and we'll go through
it together so again the half-life
formula we want to use is this one right
here okay and you can see we're starting
off with a hundred grams the base is a
half you keep cutting in half every ten
days is a half-life right but the time
is 40 days it's passed so really 40 / 10
is like four that's four half life
that's cutting it in half four times
right so if we simplify this we get one
half to the fourth power is one half
times one half times one half like four
times right which is really equal to 1
16th so this would be 100 x 116 which
would be 116th you get a decimal you
could reduce that fraction and so on but
the basic idea is you know knowing the
time the half-life and the original
amount and just being familiar with this
half-life formula which is you know a
specific type of exponential equation so
go ahead and review these formulas
memorized these formulas and I look
forward to seeing the next lesson